i um
[Music]
i feel compelled to share with you guys
a disquiet
uh a disquiet a kind of
[Music]
gnawing anxiety you feel like a fist in
the stomach that
asks the question is the juice worth
the squeeze so much sacrifice
is asked of us by the world the price
of success asks for nothing less
than everything and we wonder at times
whether we're selling
our soul i wonder myself
am i selling my soul how do i live with
integrity while still being a productive
citizen how do i you know i think it was
jamie wheel who said the difference
between the artist and the madman is the
scorecard
so there are all these ways in which in
which our
impact um or rather in which our
character is measured by
our impact and so i feel the push and
pull
of wanting to make it and wanting to
succeed and wanting to put in the time
to gain the validation and respect of
the
external world and so on and so forth
but there's also this
hunger and this disquiet between those
expectations
and my own actual desires my need
to simply be my need to destroy to
shatter my boundaries to merge with
another person to lose myself
in [ __ ] you know to explore realms of
intimacy beyond measure states of
rhapsody and consciousness of such high
res
that they take the breath away right
where are my
memories right where are those
transitory and enchanted moments that
take my breath away
where is my postcard consciousness what
are those
moments in which my self is
annihilated i lose myself i find myself
i create myself i re
renew myself right where's my holy water
where's my
baptism where's my communion where is
the relationship where is the
the space of intimacy the cosmology of
two
the intersubjective life world of me and
her together on a sailboat
outside of time right where is the
opportunity
that i that i am so hungry for
to completely disappear in the arms of
another
right i want to fall apart in the arms
of another i want to be held
while i fall apart and i want to hold
that person
when they fall apart like like that
that that opportunity right
that that that that need
for that kind of intimacy for that kind
of
communion with another being for that
kind of connection for that kind of
soul marriage right
is is something that leaves me currently
feeling
emaciated like i'm starved for it
and i'm you know and i'm surfing you
know in a creative world in which
in which everything is almost just
perfect but the fear
right the the fear of not doing enough
achieving enough not being productive
enough not leveraging the opportunity
enough like
this compulsion to stay in the hustle
right like a dog that keeps humping the
air after the
the other dog has moved away like he's
still like i just feel myself like in
this
mode sometimes and i'm you know i guess
i'm sharing this because because
whenever i
[Music]
whenever that anxiety whenever that
the compulsion of of productivity and
ticking some box and
you know doing what has to be done is
finally when that finally falls away i
find myself realizing that what i really
want is just
intimacy it's like i want to unplug from
the matrix i want to enter sacred space
you know with a woman i want to make
babies in sacred space
you know i want to be like the end of
the movie captain fantastic when they
all sing sweet child of mine together
you know like yeah like i just like
oh man find that person
and raise philosopher kings you know
like it's interesting maybe it's because
i'm in my late 30s
maybe it's because i'm in my mid to late
30s this is like jason silva's version
of a
of a quarter life crisis you know it's
like the moment of like a fork in the
road
like something has to change like i've
gotten too past a certain threshold and
i can feel the hunger for transformation
and i can heal the fung
the hunger of agitation and i have to
answer that disquiet i have to marshal a
response i can't ignore it any longer
and i'm sure people at home can resonate
i mean i'm sure you can resonate
i completely understand
see you lord it's like it's like a
surfer's always
chasing that perfect way yeah when
all he's really searching is the next
wave is to surf
so you're you're putting this place to
find
that thing that's going to be working
for you you should just do it
if it if it gives you acculations or
respect from your peers
that's extra but there's
things that you just and a lot of people
have a hard time explaining to
themselves
what they should be well i think i mean
i think it hints to a fundamental
feeling of unsafeness it's like my
default my baseline
setting it has a proclivity for feeling
unsafe
like it doesn't take much for me to feel
like i lack something like something has
to be
done like i need to justify myself or
keep myself safe like i'm not
safe if i'm not moving forward i'm
falling backwards but you can get in
this
you can get in this zone where you're on
a you're on like a jogger
you know you're on a you're on a
treadmill where you where you are
simulating the act of moving forward but
you're actually on a [ __ ] treadmill
going nowhere you're a
hamster in a hamster wheel and and you
think you're
being productive but all you're really
doing is giving up the one precious
resource you have which is
time and the the real answer to the
question is
is in bukowski's quote what does he say
i don't have what is it
i don't have any time for things that
have no soul i don't have
any time for things that have no soul
maybe that's what happens to people in
their mid to late 30s they realize
i don't have any time for things that
have no soul
i'm not surfing to win i'm surfing to
surf
i'm not a wind-up doll i'm not a
competitive
and and it's not an exhibition
surf session like i'm surfing to surf
you know i don't have to i don't have
time for things that have no soul
maybe that's really the answer to the
question then man
yeah because what's the sort of like
concrete jungle
or maze or uh whatever you want to call
it that's a soulless place when like you
see those
well i think no i think i think that
soullessness or soul sickness is what
emerges when we've realized we've sold
our soul
when we're not in integrity where we've
sold our time
sold our soul sold our mentation
sold our inner life we've we've we've
put a price on the
on our interior real estate and we've
leased it
all that's when our soul becomes sick
and and and and you know it's like you
know the the
the trivialities of modern life you know
eventually act
upon you like a pressure cooker you know
the tug of conformity and puts
guard rails upon you and then and then
you put guard rails upon yourself and
then it becomes a kind of
stockholm syndrome or you fall in love
with your
prisoner you know i just love how i feel
when i'm busy and productive you know
i'm so in love with this oppressive
state of consciousness of
anxiety and ticking the boxes of the
slot machine of petty things that bring
me no
soul and no satiation and no
satisfaction but it's okay
because i got money in the bank boom but
it's true man and so that's where the
beginning of soul sickness happens and
i'm not saying that we don't need to
survive and i'm not saying that money
is not important for whatever reason
until we move to
some next step function in an economic
system that works for all alabaki fuller
but in the meantime what i'm saying is
that we have to find a way
to live in congruence we have to
negotiate with ourselves we have to
negotiate with our psyche and we've got
to find a way of living with equanimity
grace joy
and those effervescent moments that take
our breath away and that we must not
sell
you know that's just for us
you know don't put a price on that
because it has no price
that's that's so yeah
so it's not for sale it's not for sale
man my soul's not for sale man
anyway i hope you guys found resonance
with that thank you for
thank you for watching thank you for
listening thank you for resonating thank
you for vibrating with us
i hope that um
yeah that you were that you found
reflection
in some of those reflections
in these reflections